- Na ja, ich weiß nicht …
- Ich versteh' dein Problem nicht.
- Worüber redet ihr?
- Die Zeitung, in der der Artikel über
Yaras Aktion erscheinen wird,
die würden kostenlos 'ne Annonce für
den Laden drucken.
- Das ist doch super.
- Ich glaube, der Reporter hat sich
in mich verknallt.
- Na und? Du kannst
jede Werbung gut gebrauchen.
Und du solltest jede Möglichkeit,
mit der du mehr Leute
in deinen Laden kriegst, nutzen.
- Na ja, schon.
- In welcher Rubrik würden sie
die Annonce denn platzieren?
- Die Annonce würde wahrscheinlich
im Lokalteil erscheinen.
- Sport wär' besser.
- Das entscheide ich nicht.
- Na ja, wer weiß …
- Was bedeutet Rubrik?
- Rubriken sind Teile in der Zeitung,
in denen es um verschiedene Themen geht,
wie, ähm,
Politik, Wirtschaft, Sport, Kultur …
- Kultur nennt man oft Feuilleton.
Das ist Französisch.
- Jedenfalls solltest du das Angebot, das
er dir gemacht hat, unbedingt annehmen.
Pass auf:
Ich entwerfe dir heute noch eine Annonce
und du meldest dich dafür
bei dem Reporter. Einverstanden?
Vielleicht ist er ja wirklich nett.
Immerhin bist du Single, oder?
- Hey!